okay new exclusive video also now from
our fox team the southern border shows a
mass release of single adult and mostly
male migrants into the country in
violation of a public health border
policy amid the pandemic
texas lieutenant governor dan patrick
here to talk about this what have you
learned about it what can you tell us
about it because i think the truth is
nobody really knows what's happening at
our southern border sir
yeah bill you make a great point because
the biden administration is in essence
in the smuggling business they are
smuggling people
once they get inside of america so the
borden the byte administration if you
think about this bill and dana they let
the cartels bring them in and then they
smuggle them into 49 other states they
don't tell anyone where they're going
they drop them off in the middle of the
night
they're barring cameras from coming in
to see where this particular group of
young men went that should be held in
mexico that's what they were
that's the situation they were in under
the trump administration with the mexico
protocols and the courts have said they
need to follow that so bill this is no
longer about families coming in with
children and they should not come in
illegally either this is about
young men
and and why is the bidet administration
doing this why are they sneaking them
into the country they are complicit in
smuggling people into america sir the
point um
to take it one step further
yes when our cameras are not there how
often does this happen
how often does it happen at night time
etc i'm going to show you a number here
from december we are waiting on this
number the number of encounters of the
southern board is a hundred and seventy
eight thousand eight hundred and forty
uh a year ago i mean you were still high
but you're only at seventy four thousand
that number on the right
uh when our viewers are watching the nfl
playoffs this weekend okay and they're
watching the chiefs and bengals at
arrowhead stadium arrowhead stadium
seats 76 000 people that number on the
screen is almost two and a half times
the number of people who can sit inside
of that stadium on a given sunday and we
saw that many encounters in 30 days sir
yes bill that's why we're spending
nearly four billion dollars of our
texans taxpayer money to start building
the wall we sent thousands of national
guard to the border we're doing
everything we can but the biden
administration is smug help helping to
smuggle people into this country and
it's for a purpose they want them to
become citizens they want them to vote
one day because they see that as a grab
of power and they don't care who dies
in the way we are going to have a
funeral this week for
border special agent dps one of our
troopers
anthony salas he died last week he was
killed it was an accident after he had
apprehended some illegal immigrants
those watching in the white house
communications room right now which i
know they do they watch your show every
morning understand that your boss
this is on him every death
that that occurs from people crossing
this country illegally
is on your boss's policies
too many have died and bill by the way
if i could just mention this because
look border patrol dps they're all part
of law enforcement people are sick to
death in this country of what we see now
the black lives matter organization
talking about when they say you know
just because a cop dies in line of duty
doesn't make him a hero they're tired of
seeing tear jerking press conferences
you know they don't want to hear about
these things they talk about barbecuing
uh propaganda i'm sick of it and you
mentioned football bill i know you're a
big sports fan like i am there's been a
lot of talk about a coin toss i'm going
to toss it right here the nba the nfl
and corporate america needs to decide
heads or tails heads you're with law and
order and you're with police or tails
you're with an organization black lives
matter that believes that when a hero
when an officer dies in line of duty
that he's not a hero
and and it's not acceptable corporate
america needs to wake up and get off
this organization i have 15 seconds why
has joe biden yes never been part of
southern why has joe biden never been to
the southern border
bill look he won't even admit this is a
crisis uh he's either sleeping at the
switch or he's doing this purposely now
i know they call him sleepy joe he's not
that sleepy he knows what's happening on
the border he's allowing it to happen he
doesn't care that special agent anthony
salas died last week i bet he hasn't
called the family i bet he won't be at
the funeral i'm tired of going to law
enforcement's funeral whether it's
border agents or police officers by his
policies to that point
we'll see if that question comes up
today at the white house briefing when
that occurs thank you dan patrick there
in texas thank you good luck down there